WE WILL SEE YOU TOMORROW NIGHT
AT 7:00.
>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
HAPPY MONDAY.
ONE OF THE GREAT UNSOLVED
MYSTERIES OF THE PAST FOUR YEARS
AS WHY CERTAIN TYPES OF PEOPLE
WITH CERTAIN TYPES OF JOBS HATE
DONALD TRUMP SO MUCH, REALLY
HATE HIM, OBSESS OVER HIM.
THINK ABOUT HIM WHEN THEY WAKE
UP IN THE MORNING, WOULD HURT
HIM IF THEY COULD’VE CREATED BY
THE FIXATION?
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
REASONS NORMAL PEOPLE SOMETIMES
GET ANNOYED WITH TRUMP, THE
BRAGGING COME WITH A SHORT
ATTENTION SPAN, THE RANTS ON
TWITTER.
NONE OF THAT COMES WITH HEAT OR
RIB SESSION.
PLENTY OF POLITICIANS OF
UNAPPEALING PERSONAL PROBLEMS.
THE REASON THE RULING CLASS
DESPISES DONALD TRUMP IS BECAUSE
THEY CAN’T CONTROL HIM.
HE REFUSES TO MOUNT THEIR LYRICS
AND WILL NOT OBEY.
HE IS LIABLE TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY NOT
ALLOWED TO SAY.
BORDERS MAKE COUNTRY, CHINA IS
OUR ENEMY, WHOOPI GOLDBERG IS IN
THAT FUNDING.
ALL OF IT UNDENIABLY TRUE AND
THAT’S THE POINT AND THE
PROBLEM.
TRUMPS WORDS HANG IN THE AIR FOR
ALL TO SEE AND TO ASSESS AND
THEY ARE THERE FOR A MASSIVE
THREAT TO PEOPLE WHOSE
LIVELIHOODS DEPEND UPON FRAUD
AND LYING.
TRUMP IS THE MOST DANGEROUS TO
HIS ENEMIES WHEN HE’S TELLING
THE TRUTH.
IN FACT, ENEMIES PRECISELY
BECAUSE HE DOES TELL THE TRUTH
AND HE DID THE OTHER DAY.
ON FRIDAY, THE PRESIDENT GAVE A
SPEECH AT MOUNT RUSHMORE, SPOKE
ELOQUENTLY ABOUT THE BLM RIOTS
AND WHAT THEY MEAN FOR THE
COUNTRY.
HERE’S PART OF IT.
>> MAKE NO MISTAKE, THIS
LEFT-WING CULTURAL REVOLUTION IS
DESIGNED TO OVERTHROW THE
AMERICAN REVOLUTION.
IN SO DOING, THEY WOULD DESTROY
THE VERY CIVILIZATION THAT
RESCUED MILLIONS FROM POVERTY,
DISEASE, VIOLENCE, AND HUNGER
AND LIFTED HUMANITY TO NEW
HEIGHTS OF ACHIEVEMENT,
DISCOVERY, AND PROGRESS.
TO MAKE THIS POSSIBLE, THEY ARE
DETERMINED TO TEAR DOWN EVERY
STATUE, SYMBOL, AND MEMORY OF
OUR NATIONAL HERITAGE.
>> Tucker: OUR NATIONAL
HERITAGE.
IT’S SOMETHING WE CAN BE PROUD
OF.
THIS COUNTRY DEFEATED BOTH
FASCISM AND COMMUNISM.
OUR REVOLUTION INSPIRED
DEMOCRATIC REVOLUTIONS AROUND
THE WORLD BUT EVEN NOW, PRO
FREEDOM DEMONSTRATORS WAIVE THE
AMERICAN FLAG TO EXPRESS THEIR
HOPE AND THEIR DEFIANCE.
OUR ECONOMY AND OUR SCHOOLS
CREATED THE WORLD’S FIRST AND
THE GREATEST EDUCATED
MIDDLE-CLASS.
ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS IN THE
TRANSFORMED AGRICULTURE.
THEY ENDED FAMINE ON MOST OF THE
GLOBE.
OUR RICHEST CITIZENS BECAME
FAMOUS NOT FOR THE PALACES THEY
BUILT FOR THEMSELVES BUT FOR THE
PHILANTHROPY THEY GAVE TO
OTHERS.
BUILT COUNTLESS LIBRARIES FOR
THE POOR.
JOHN D ROCKEFELLER IN THE SOUTH.
THESE ARE NOT THE DEEDS OF AN
EVIL COUNTRY, THEY ARE THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF A GREAT
COUNTRY.
YET AS THE PRESIDENT POINTED
OUT, AMERICAN SCHOOLCHILDREN USE
NONE OF THIS.
INSTEAD, OUR CURRICULA HAS
BECOME A TOXIC MIX OF LIES AND
INFORMATIONOMISSION DESIGNED TO
>> AGAINST EVERY LAW OF SOCIETY
AND NATURE, OUR CHILDREN ARE
TAUGHT IN SCHOOL TO HATE THEIR
OWN COUNTRY AND TO BELIEVE THAT
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO BUILT IT
WERE NOT HEROES, BUT WHERE
VILLAINS.
THE RADICAL VIEW OF AMERICAN
HISTORY IS A WEB OF LIES, ALL
PERSPECTIVE IS REMOVED, EVERY
MOTIVE IS TWISTED, EVERY FACT IS
DISTORTED, AND EVERY FLAW IS
MAGNIFIED.
UNTIL THE HISTORY IS PURGED AND
THE RECORD IS DISFIGURED BEYOND
ALL RECOGNITION.
>> Tucker: EVERY WORD OF THAT
IS TRUE.
YOU HAVE KIDS IN SCHOOL, YOU
KNOW IT MAY EVEN BE AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN OUR
CLASSROOMS RIGHT NOW IN 2,020 IS
A CRIME.
IS LONG PAST TIME THAT A SITTING
PRESIDENT SAID SO AND THEN TRUMP
KEPT GOING.
TOWARDS THE END OF HIS SPEECH,
HE DEFENDED THE CORE PROMISE OF
AMERICA, THE PRINCIPAL THIS
COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED ON.
THE ONLY PRINCIPLE THAT WILL
ALLOW AMERICA TO SURVIVE GOING
FORWARD, AND NATION WERE ALL
CITIZENS ARE EQUAL FROM BIRTH
AND AS A RESULT ENJOYED EQUAL
RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW.
IT’S WHAT OUR DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE DESCRIBES.
>> WE BELIEVE IN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY, EQUAL JUSTICE, AND
EQUAL TREATMENT FOR CITIZENS OF
EVERY RACE, BACKGROUND,
RELIGION, AND CREATED.
EVERY CHILD OF EVERY COLOR BORN
AND UNBORN IS MADE IN THE HOLY
IMAGE OF GOD.
WE WANT FREE AND OPEN DEBATE,
NOT SPEECH CODES AND CANCEL
CULTURE.
WE EMBRACE TOLERANCE, NOT
PREJUDICE.
WE SUPPORT THE COURAGEOUS MEN
AND WOMEN OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE WILL NEVER ABOLISH OUR POLICE
OR OUR GREAT SECOND AMENDMENT
WHICH GIVES US THE RIGHT TO KEEP
AND BEAR ARMS.
WE BELIEVE THAT OUR CHILDREN
SHOULD BE TAUGHT TO LOVE THEIR
COUNTRY, HONOR THEIR HISTORY,
AND RESPECT OUR GREAT AMERICAN
FLAG.
WE STAND TALL, WE STAND PROUD,
AND WE ONLY KNEEL TO ALMIGHTY
GOD.
THIS IS WHO WE ARE.
THIS IS WHAT WE BELIEVE.
AND THESE ARE THE VALUES THAT
WILL GUIDE US AS WE STRIVE TO
BUILD AN EVEN BETTER AND GREATER
FUTURE.
>> Tucker: WE ALMOST NEVER
PLAY SOUND BITES THAT ARE LONG.
POLITICIANS OF WHERE THEY A
SPEECH IS WORTHY OF THEM, MOST
OF WHAT THEY SAY IS GARBAGE AND
WE DON’T WANT TO REPEAT ABOVE
FRIDAY’S ADDRESS AT
MOUNT RUSHMORE WAS PROBABLY THE
SINGLE BEST SPEECH DONALD TRUMP
IS EVER GIVEN.
WAS A ROAD MAP FOR HIS
REELECTION METHOD, BUT MORE THAN
THAT, A ROAD MAP FOR THE COUNTRY
ITSELF.
OF EQUALITY, DECENCY, PRIDE IN
OUR NATION.
THAT’S WHY THE LIARS ON
TELEVISION DEEPLY HATED EVERY
WORD OF IT.
>> THERE IS REALLY A MYTH OF
AMERICA, THIS IDEA THAT AMERICA
TREATED PEOPLE WELL, TREATED MEN
AND WOMEN EQUALLY, THAT WE
STARTED THIS COUNTRY WITH HER
OWN WITS.
>> MUCH OF AMERICA POLITICAL
PROPAGANDA OVER THE COURSE OF
OUR HISTORY HAS TRIED TO
COMPLETELY ERASE, IGNORE, LIE
ABOUT THE UGLY PARTS OF OUR
HISTORY.
>> MOUNT RUSHMORE IS IN EXACTLY
THE INNOCENT OWED TO OUR
FOUNDING FATHERS AS DESCRIBED IN
OUR TEXTBOOKS AND IT’S HIGH TIME
WE DISRUPT THAT FALSE NARRATIVE
THAT FAR TOO MANY PEOPLE
BELIEVE.
HERE WE ARE CELEBRATING THE
BIRTH OF A NATION, INDEPENDENCE
FOR WHITE MEN AT A SITE
DESCRIBED BY ONE NATIVE AMERICAN
ACTIVIST AS "A SYMBOL OF WHITE
SUPREMACY."
>> Tucker: IF YOU SPEND THE
REST OF YOUR LIFE TRYING TO
IDENTIFY THE WORST PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY AND 330 MILLION,
YOU COULDN’T GET A PURE
DISTILLATION OF WHAT YOU JUST
SAW.
THESE PEOPLE ARE LIARS BY THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO SPENT THE LAST
MONTH TELLING YOU THAT THE RIOTS
USE ALL LIVE ON TELEVISION WERE
ACTUALLY PEACEFUL PROTESTS
AGAINST RACISM.
THAT WAS ALIVE.
THEY KNEW IT WAS A LIE WHEN THEY
SAID IT, BUT THEY SAID IT ANYWAY
IN ORDER TO UNDERMINE A COUNTRY
THAT THEY HATE.
AMERICA DESERVES TO BE IN
FLAMES, THAT IS THEIR VIEW AND
THIS WEEKEND, THEY SAID IT
ESSENTIALLY OUT LOUD.
MOUNT RUSHMORE, THEY TOLD US,
MUST GO.
IS ILLEGITIMATE, JUST LIKE THE
NATION IT CELEBRATES.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BE AT
MOUNT RUSHMORE WHERE HE WILL BE
STANDING IN FRONT OF A MONUMENT
OF TWO SLAVE OWNERS AND ON LAND
WRESTLED AWAY FROM
NATIVE AMERICANS.
>> THESE MONUMENTS WE DON’T WANT
TO FORGET, WHAT DO WE DO WITH
THEM?
MAY BE DON’T STAND IN THE TOWN
SQUARE BUT SHOULD THEY STAND
ANYWHERE?
SHOULD WE DEMOLISH THEM?
>> IT’S BEEN POLLUTED, IT’S BEEN
DESECRATED BY PUTTING THE
SLAVE-OWNING, RACIST, HORRIBLE
WHITE MEN IN 60-FOOT STATUES ON
THIS WALL.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS PLACE,
THIS LAND, THE BLACK HILLS, THE
HISTORY IS A DARK ONE.
>> IT IS NOT JUST THE LAND THAT
HAS BEEN STOLEN IN A PLACE LIKE
MOUNT RUSHMORE AND THE BLACK
HILLS, IT’S THE THEFT OF
HISTORY, THE THEFT OF THE
NARRATIVE.
>> WORTH REMINDING FOLKS THAT
THE MAN WHO CARVED THE MONUMENT
BEHIND ME HAD DEEP TIES TO THE
KKK.
>> THE MOTHER OF ALL PHOTO OPS,
MOUNT RUSHMORE AND WE KNOW WHY
THIS PRESIDENT JUST CAN’T RESIST
GOING THERE.
>> Tucker: SO MOUNT RUSHMORE
IS NOW A SYMBOL OF EVIL JUST
LIKE YOUR NATION.
WHERE IS THIS ALL GOING?
AS THE WRITER PUT IT, CNN EVEN
PUT INDEPENDENCE" WHEN
DESCRIBING THE HOLIDAY.
THIS END WITH WOLF BLITZER
DRESSED PULLING THE SWITCH TO
DYNAMITE THE STATUE OF LIBERTY.
PRETTY FUNNY, BUT SUDDENLY,
GETTING EASIER TO IMAGINE THAT
HAPPENING.
ON THE MORNING OF JULY 4TH,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SUMMARIZE
THE PRESIDENT’S SPEECH, THE
CLIPS OF WHAT WE JUST PLAYED
THIS WAY.
"PRESIDENT TRUMP’S UNYIELDING
PUSH TO PRESERVE CONFEDERATE
SYMBOLS AND THE LEGACY OF WHITE
DOMINATION CRYSTALLIZED BY HIS
HARSH DENUNCIATION OF THE RACIAL
JUSTICE MOVEMENT FRIDAY NIGHT AT
MOUNT RUSHMORE HAS UNNERVED
REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE LONG
ENABLED HIM.
"FOR REAL.
THAT WAS NOT AN OPINION PIECE ON
THE OP-ED PAGE, IT WAS A NEWS
STORY WRITTEN BY TWO
"WASHINGTON POST" REPORTERS.
THEY DESCRIBED A DEFENSE OF
EQUALITY UNDER THE LAW IS
"TRUMP’S PUSH TO RACISM."
JEFF BEZOS’ NEWSPAPER.
LOCAL POLITICIANS JOIN THE
CHORUS.
THE MAYOR OF NASHVILLE CANCELED
FIREWORKS BUT ALLOWED BLM
PROTEST TO CONTINUE UNIMPEDED.
ENRICHMENT, ORDERED A
CONSTRUCTION SITE TO REMOVE AN
AMERICAN FLAG.
WAS TWO PROVOCATIVE THEY SAID,
MEANWHILE THE STATUE OF MASS
MURDERER VLADIMIR LENIN STANDS
COMPLETELY UNMOLESTED IN THE
CITY OF SEATTLE.
OFFICIALS THERE SEE NOTHING
PROVOCATIVE ABOUT IT.
SO WHERE IS JOE BIDEN ON ALL OF
THIS IS THE REVOLUTION
CONTINUES?
BIDEN IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
MODERATE, REMEMBER?
THAT WAS HIS CHIEF APPEAL.
BUT THERE’S NOTHING MODERATE
ABOUT BIDEN’S FOURTH OF JULY
STATEMENT.
INSTEAD, A FULL THROATED ATTACK
ON THE UNITED STATES.
>> OUR COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED ON AN
IDEA.
WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE
SELF-EVIDENT.
ALL MEN ARE CREATED EQUAL.
JEFFERSON HIMSELF DIDN’T.
HE HELD, WOMEN WERE EXCLUDED.
AMERICA IS JUST NO FAIRY TALE.
IT’S BEEN A CONSTANT PUSH AND
PULL BETWEEN TWO PARTS OF OUR
CHARACTER.
THE IDEA THAT ALL MEN AND WOMEN,
ALL PEOPLE ARE CREATED EQUAL,
AND THE RACISM THAT HAS TORN US
APART.
WE HAVE A CHANCE TO RIP THE
ROOTS OF SYSTEMIC RACISM OUT OF
THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: THAT’S YOUR
FOURTH OF JULY MESSAGE?
SYSTEMIC RACISM, SOMETHING YOU
CAN EVEN DEFINE THAT HAS NO REAL
DEFINITION, REALLY?
LIKING YOUR FINGER IN THE FACE
OF THE NATION TO PROMOTE SOMEONE
AS MEDIOCRE AS YOU TO THE
POSITION YOU CURRENTLY HOLD?
THIS IS THE MAN COULD SOON BE
OUR FIGUREHEAD, BUT HOW ABOUT
THE ACTUAL PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE, WHOEVER BIDEN PICKS
AS HIS VP RUNNING MATE?
SENATOR TAMMY DUCKWORTH OF
ILLINOIS A TOP CONTENDER FOR THE
JOB.
YOU’RE NOT SUPPOSED TO CRITICIZE
TAMMY DUCKWORTH IN ANYWAY
BECAUSE SHE ONCE SERVED IN THE
MILITARY.
MOST PEOPLE JUST IGNORE HER.
BUT WHEN SHE DOES SPEAK IN
PUBLIC, HE REMINDED WHAT A
DEEPLY SILLY AND UNIMPRESSIVE
PERSON SHE IS.
HERE IS TAMMY DUCKWORTH OVER THE
WEEKEND TELLING US IT’S TIME TO
GET RID OF GEORGE WASHINGTON.
>> I KNOW THAT YOU SUPPORT
CHANGING THE NAME OF MILITARY
BASES NAMED AFTER CONFEDERATE
LEADERS, BUT THERE ARE LEADERS
LIKE GEORGE WASHINGTON AND
THOMAS JEFFERSON WHO WERE
SLAVE OWNERS AND SOME PEOPLE ARE
DEMANDING THAT THEIR MONUMENTS
COME DOWN TOO.
IN YOUR VIEW, WHERE DOES IT END?
SHOULD STATUES OF
GEORGE WASHINGTON COME DOWN?
>> LET ME JUST SAY THAT WE
SHOULD START OFF BY HAVING A
NATIONAL DIALOGUE ON IT AT SOME
POINT.
>> Tucker: A NATIONAL
DIALOGUE, PLEASE.
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING FOR ANY
KIND OF COLLOQUY.
WHAT THEY WANT IS A SOLILOQUY.
YOUWE SPEAK, YOU SHUT UP AND
LISTEN.
IT’S BEEN CONSIDERED
OUT-OF-BOUNDS TO QUESTION A
PERSON’S PATRIOTISM.
A VERY STRONG CHARGE AND WE TRY
NOT TO MAKE IT BUT IN THE FACE
OF ALL OF THIS, THE CONCLUSION
CAN’T BE AVOIDED.
THESE PEOPLE ACTUALLY HATE
AMERICA.
NO LONGER A QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
AND YET AT THE SAME TIME, THEY
DESPERATELY WANT TO CONTROL
AMERICA MORE THAN ANYTHING.
AND THAT LEADS TO THE MOST BASIC
OF ALL QUESTIONS, CAN YOU REALLY
LEAD A COUNTRY THAT YOU HATE?
ASK YOURSELF WHAT KIND OF PARENT
WOULD YOU BE IF YOU HATED YOUR
CHILDREN?
WHAT KIND OF OFFICE OR WOULD YOU
MAKE IF YOU DIDN’T CARE ABOUT
YOUR TROOPS?
IT WOULD BE AWFUL.
THE RESULTS WOULD BE UGLY.
WOULD NOT WORK.
LOVING THE PEOPLE YOU LEAD AND
CARING DEEPLY ABOUT THEM IS THE
BASIC PREREQUISITE OF
LEADERSHIP.
THE LEADERS OF TODAY’S
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DO NOT.
THEY DESPISE THIS COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE SAID SO.
THEY CONTINUE TO YOU.
THAT IS SHOCKING, BUT IT IS ALSO
DISQUALIFYING.
WE CANNOT LET THEM RUN THIS